the term projection is derived from
classical psychoanalysis and is regarded
as a primitive ego defense mechanism I'm
going to use three references in
discussing this issue the first is a
very good dictionary of psychoanalysis
written in 1973 by Laplace and Pantelis
called the language of psychoanalysis
even though this is clearly not a
Jungian text I found that it's extremely
useful over the years in making sense of
the scope of Jung's analytical
psychology which as many of you already
know is based on core Freudian ideas
young however transformed the classical
psychoanalytic theory of Freud into a
more dynamic field called analytical
psychology remember that young began his
psychoanalytic career as an ardent
psychoanalyst and was a colleague and
student of Freud until their ideological
break in 1913 1914 the second source is
Jung himself and the third source is
another important text that I have
hardly recommended and continue to do so
being Andrew Samuels a critical
dictionary of analytical psychology
I will repeat these titles of these
books at the end of the podcast so back
to the idea of projection let's start
with a classical definition from Laplace
and Ponte Lisa and they say that
projection is and I quote an operation
whereby qualities feelings wishes or
even objects which the subject refuses
to recognize or rejects in himself are
expelled from the self and located in
another person or thing end quote
now let's contrast that with Jung's
definition which reads as follows then I
quote projection means the expulsion of
a subjective content into an object it
is the opposite of introjection
it is a process of dissimulation by
which a subject of content becomes
alienated from the subject and is so to
speak embodied in the object both
definitions are structured in a similar
manner projection is a process or an
operation in which subject of content
such as qualities feelings wishes or
even objects which an individual cannot
recognize in him or herself are expelled
and then located in another personal
thing a key term needs to be added to
our definition and that is that whatever
is expelled or projected is unconscious
we don't know we're doing this and we
seldom know what it is that is being
projected important here to note is that
projection is a very normal very natural
process in the psyche we project all the
time especially when dealing with other
people do you remember meeting someone
for the first time and they felt
familiar as though you had known them
from before and as your conversation
went on you started to see that they
spoke or behaved just like someone you
already know say a sibling or an
acquaintance then you began to realize
that you expected them to hold certain
attitudes or beliefs or that you found
yourself distancing yourself from the
other person because you already know
what they held in terms of beliefs and
you don't like these beliefs you found
some of their attitudes unattractive
this was projection very little of the
real information about this new person
was actually present in the interaction
as most of it came from within you an
excellent summary of our definition is
offered by Andrew Samuels in his
critical dictionary of analytical
psychology and I quote Jung's approach
to projection builds upon a
psychoanalytic base projection may be
seen as normal
or pathological and as a defense against
anxiety difficult emotions and
unacceptable parts of the personality
may be located in a person or object
external to the subject the problematic
content is thereby controlled and the
individual feels a release and a sense
of well-being in analytical psychology
stress has also been laid on projection
as the means by which the contents of
the inner world are made available to
ego consciousness the assumption is that
an encounter between the ego and such
unconscious contents is of value the
external world of persons and things
serves the internal world by providing
the raw material to be activated by
projection this can be seen most clearly
when what is projected is also
representative of a part of the psyche
anima and animus projections are carried
by real men and women without the
carrier there would be no meeting
similarly the shadow is frequently
encountered in projection by definition
the shadow is the repository of what is
unacceptable to consciousness
it is therefore ripe for projection for
anything of value to be gained though it
is necessary for some reintegration or
recollection of that which is projected
to take place end quote so we can see
how Samuels enlarges our idea of
projection but critically uses as his
prime examples the archetypes of the
shadow the anima and the animus we can
also understand that there are definite
series or stages that we engage in when
we project when we become aware of the
discrepancy between the real person and
the projections we make onto that real
person we are starting to withdraw our
projections
this means that we are seeing the person
for whom he or she really is and not
using them as a movie theater screen to
project our movies on to this is a way
to understand projection that of a movie
screen it is almost as if when we meet
someone and start to project we are
treating them like a movie screen a
blank canvas that we then fill with
images from a movie that the unconscious
generates about that person although
none of the projections are based on
hardcore facts they are psychically real